على ذكر رفيق الحريري في كتابك الذي لخصت
في مسيرتك الدبلوماسيه نفهم انك تتهم
النظام السوري باغتيال رفيق الحريري بناء
على ماذا جاء هذا الاستنتاج
لا استطيع ان اقول انني اتهم النظام
السوري بذلك ففي ذلك الوقت كما تعلمين
به لجنه تحقق على الارض وتم طبعا استجواب
شهود وتم توقيف بعض الاشخاص كل ذلك جرى في
سياق بالغ صعوبه
والتعقيد في لبنان وفي المنطقه ايضا كان
هناك عدد من الوقائع جعلتنا نتساءل ولكن
لم يعد لنا ولا يمكن ان نقول له شخصيا
لا يمكن نقول ان سوريا هي المسؤوله كان
هناك عوامل تجعلنا نعتقد بان رفيق الحريري
كان يزعج وان اختفائه كان يخدم مصالح
البعض لا استطيع ان اضيف اكثر من ذلك بس
الى اي حد يمكن ان نقول بانه فرنسا
فشلت في قضيه المحكمه الدوليه تجاه رفيق
الحريري
من فشل ليست فرنسا وانما المجتمع الدولي
برمته فقد اشرت الى التعقيدات على الارض
لاجراء تحقيق وكذلك الاعتراضات التي تجلت
في اماكن متعدده لعرقله التحقيق وكذلك
الوقت الذي
احتجته لجنه تحقيق لاستجواب بعض الاشخاص
اذا لم نتوصل
لتحديد مسؤوليات المسؤوليات في هذا هذا
الاغتيال هذا فشل هل هو فشل فرنسا ام
لبنان اعتقد انه فشل جماعي للاسف والوضع
اليوم يظل بالغ التوتر والصعوبه